in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Jeff
and Rachel are with us hey guys how are
you good good to meet you welcome it's
good to have you where you guys live
we're just outside of Salt Lake City
Utah very cool well welcome to Nashville
and all the way over here on the other
side of the United States to do your
debt-free scream yeah yes I did to do it
we're good to have you how much have you
paid off forty-five thousand forty five
thousand dollars and how long did that
take twenty two months good for you and
your range of income during that time
started at 50 and ended around 90 Wow
way to go guys so you almost doubled
your income how'd you do that in 22
months changed jobs and found some good
opportunities wow that's a launch mhm
man that's impressive what do you guys
do I'm a Salesforce solution architect
for a consulting company now of course
you are you have a couple of those
onboard here very cool I'm a registered
nurse but currently I'm on break to stay
home with kiddos I love it
well that's neat good what kind of debt
was the forty five thousand student
loans
yeah so what happened twenty two months
ago that made you guys get serious about
getting out of debt what flipped the
switch well we had gotten home from a
Disney trip that we had saved to pay
cash for and after the trip we had three
hundred bucks that we just put right
into the student loans and I felt you
know we've got the motivation let's
knock these suckers out mm-hmm okay cool
and so what made you think you could do
that or should do that I'm just that you
know with saving up for the trip mm-hmm
that we were able to do it and then
we've had some friends who have been
taking the FPU and so we borrowed their
CDs from okay cool and we went to the
class our own this past winter okay good
and just kept the ball going okay so
that kind of got you started but then
you got in the class and it kept you
moving oh yes
I got you very cool very cool so when
people find out you payments 2,000 bucks
a month over that that you
eight on average you got it after you
knocked all Sallie Mae in the head yeah
so what what what do you tell people the
most important thing you're gonna do if
you're gonna get out of debt is have the
thing that we've talked about most is
paying tithes and offerings just having
that divine help mm-hmm we needed that
and then constant motivation there's
something that happens when you put
giving at the top of your budget that
turns everything else loose yeah it's
very real it's not that it's really not
even that mystical no you know it just
happens it's just a very real thing well
very cool guys congratulations you
that's fine so what was the hardest part
of this for you to finding sources of
motivation for me I'm a frequent
listener of your show and so this holds
a lot and then I don't know if you have
a picture up I went to the Salt Lake
City SmartMoney event in May okay and
that helped I went with a friend and I
got a picture made with Rachael there it
is on the screen okay yeah my friend
says it's a rock concert for nerds
anything for you I love it that's very
fun that's very cool
all right and you brought the two kiddos
with you and other names and their ages
so Rory our daughter she is six men
Eddie is four oh very cool they have
been the frequent listeners with mom on
car rights okay so they say know about
the debt free scream boy do they and
have they been practicing oh yeah are
they gonna be good at the debt free
scream are they gonna scream hey Rory
are you gonna scream loud at the debt
free scream hey Rachel are your loud
screamer
all right good because this is important
your mom and dad have changed your life
this is very cool stuff well very cool
you guys I'm very proud of you we've got
a copy of Chris Hogan's book retire
inspired signed by him for you as our
gift because that's the next chapter in
your life now getting out of that's just
the first thing you do then you build
wealth and change your family tree and
be able to be in a position to can
continue the giving but also increase it
so well done alright it's Jeff and
Rachel Rory and Eddie I love it very
cool from Salt Lake City $45,000 paid
off in 22 months making fifty to ninety
thousand count it down
let's hear a debt free scream to
I love it I love it I love it very cool
very cool very proud of you all
excellent excellent job that is how it's
done folks
and I love that hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
you
[Music]